Що спільного між колишнім американським дипломатом..?
В Україну мене привела моя робота. Я був дипломатом американського посольства.
Українським актором театру і кіно..?
Я працюю в театрі на Печерську.
І людьми, які ламають стереотипи щодо своїх діагнозів..?
Сам я живу не на квартирі, я живу в інтернаті.
Усі вони печуть хліб для прифронтових і деокупованих територій.
Приміром, ці буханці ось-ось поїдуть на Харківщину.
Весь рік ми продовжуємо пекти хліб. Спочатку ми його пекли для Києва:
для поліції, військових, для людей в укриттях, в метро. Потім переключилися на деокуповану
Київську область, пізніше це була Чернігівська область, а зараз переважно
це деокупована Харківська область, Донецька область. Також передаємо
в Херсонську, Миколаївську і їздимо в Запорізьку області.
Ця пекарня відома тим, що в ній працюють люди з ментальною інвалідністю.
Двадцять три працівники мають різні діагнози,
з якими в Україні знайти роботу практично неможливо.
Синдром Дауна, аутизм, психіатричні діагнози, абсолютно різні. І наша історія в тому,
що ми намагаємося знайти підхід і зрозуміти підхід кожної людини.
Пекарня першопочатково створювалася як місце, де будуть навчатися, соціалізуватися саме дорослі люди
з ментальною інвалідністю, для яких поки що у нас в країні немає можливості реалізувати себе.
Катерині двадцять сім. Вона здобула професію кухаря-кондитера, пройшла практику, проте з роботою…
довго не складалося.
Я намагалася влаштуватись на роботу, але мені або казали, що ми вам передзвонимо,
або просто казали: "Ти не впораєшся".
А в пекарні в неї повірили. І ось уже три роки Катерина, як сама каже, працює на улюбленій роботі.
Тут знайшла не лише нових друзів, а й покликання.
Я відчуваю, що я чимось допомагаю. Можна сказати, що так я дякую нашим військовим ЗСУ,
що я живу під мирним небом, що я досі жива.
Кожна хлібина - маленький внесок у боротьбу з агресією Росії.
Тож пекарі, які мають ментальну інвалідність, тут відчувають свою значимість.
І це має неабияку терапевтичну дію.
Звичайно, важливо. Це ж хліб віддається людям, які потребують його.
Тому я думаю, що це дуже добре, що ми це робимо.
Щоденно у пекарні виготовляють до двох тисяч буханців.
Робота кипить з самого ранку й до вечора.
Наростити виробництво допомагають волонтери, які після вторгнення Росії долучилися
до команди пекарні. Ввечері Ігор грає на сцені столичного театру, а вдень опановує мистецтво випікання хлібу.
Я ніколи не думав, що я буду щось пекти у своєму житті, ніколи, я навіть на кухні раніше не часто з'являвся.
Але тепер мені це дуже подобається. Я ходжу до театру, й мені всі кажуть: "Від тебе пахне хлібом".
А я кажу: "От добре, що я пішов не в оселедочну якусь там".
Час від часу пекарі самотужки доставляють хліб на фронт і у прифронтові регіони.
Приміром, у листопаді Ігор їздив у Бахмут.
Ми зустрічали якихось людей, спілкувалися й, в принципі, люди є люди.
Тобто вони намагаються жити, вони сподіваються на краще. Вони вірять, надіються…
Крім акторів, у цій пекарні вже майже рік хліб пече колишній американський дипломат.
В Україну мене привела моя робота. Я був дипломатом американського посольства.
Я працював дипломатом, був радником при міністерстві оборони.
У березні 2021 року я вийшов на пенсію, але вирішив залишитися в Києві.
Чи відтоді бодай раз думав виїхати з України?
Ні-ні-ні-ні! Ніколи!
Україну Патрік називає своїм домом. І уже понад пів року вчить українську мову.
Мені подобається думати, що я патріот. Адже я роблю все можливе, щоби захистити свій дім.
Тому я і став волонтером у цій пекарні. Я хочу допомогти країні. І це був найкращий спосіб,
який я міг знайти, щоб допомогти тим, кому пощастило менше, ніж нам.
Допомагає пекарня й українським військовим. Зазвичай на передову передають не лише хліб, а й кекси.
Крім того, команда вже розпочала підготовку до Великодня.
Ось такі патріотичні паски поїдуть на фронт і прифронтові території у квітні.
Підтримати пекарню пожертвою може кожен охочий.